Wayne Dyer is called the father of
motivation he's the author of over 30
books and he was one of the most
recognized writers and speakers on the
topic of self-development and
spirituality in this video I'll be
breaking down Wayne Dyer's most powerful
lessons on manifesting what you want
teaching you how to realign yourself and
all your thoughts by removing the
obstacles from within and the outside
forces that pull us away from our dreams
and desires Wayne Dyer's experience
growing up through tough times led him
to the path of self-empowerment he had a
massive impact on the personal
development space and he held Pioneer
spirituality in the west he dedicated
his life to learning and teaching these
ideas I'll be guiding you through some
of Wayne's most powerful life lessons
that will help you create a path to what
you want to your version of success and
happiness
my father had walked out on us when I
was just a baby my mother had three boys
under the age of four during the Great
Depression war was getting ready to
start all over the planet World War II
and he just took off and I spent my
youth into my 20s trying to find this
man Wayne literally came from nothing
and achieved greatness the early years
of his life were difficult as his father
was an alcoholic and left his family
when Wayne was only three years old
forcing him to be put in a series of
foster homes until age 10. he grew up in
the era right after the Great Depression
and during World War II at that time
people were consumed by the unknown and
uncertainty they were being drafted to
fight in a war and America was
recovering from the economic downturn
his teachings are more relevant now than
ever once again our world is filled with
unknown and uncertainty with
International conflict climate change
and a rapid evolution in technology in
today's modern society it's especially
challenging with all the digital noise
there is a constant stream of
information that is bombarding your mind
making you feel overwhelmed and leaving
you mentally exhausted dulling the
senses and pulling you away from
becoming the best version of yourself
it's a modern challenge that we Face
being pulled away from what we desire
and the things that are truly important
to us our minds and thoughts are
distracted and fragmented as the outside
world becomes more advanced the more we
must go inside ourselves for inspiration
be in touch with our spirituality and
listen to our thoughts basically it all
begins with how we choose to think
as you think
so shall you be
seven little words that I think are
perhaps the most important things that
we can learn and master in our lives
Wayne Dyer says that you are not a human
being having a spiritual experience it's
the other way around your spiritual
being having a human experience the
quality of your Human Experience depends
on how you use this energy this
invisible intelligence we must learn how
to connect to it there are higher levels
of awareness that are available to each
and every one of us this energy is
within and all around us it goes by many
names higher human awareness higher
Consciousness Universal energy the
Divine Source infinite intelligence the
soul the list goes on and on it doesn't
matter what you call it it's a powerful
Source that's always there we can't see
it because it's not in the material
world it's invisible to the human eye
and weightless because it's in the world
of the spirit
we've been conditioned to not pay
attention to this energy we don't notice
it even though it surrounds us at all
times we put obstacles in the way and
limitations on what we think is possible
so that we only experience life at
ordinary levels of awareness we've
blocked our connection to this higher
level of Consciousness Dyer has a great
metaphorical story to illustrate the
point life is like being born into a a
room a mansion if you will that has a
thousand rooms but you're born into one
room and this one room is called
daily human awareness and the only way
you can get in is through conception and
birth
you're in and the only way you can get
out
is to die
so we spend our lives in this mansion in
one room even those there's 999 other
rooms we don't know how to get out into
those rooms unless we die so we wait to
die I can teach you how to get out of
the room of daily awareness
and into the other 999 rooms and if you
stay with me
and learn all that I have to give you
I can teach you how to get out of the
house all together without having to die
he teaches us how to get out of our own
way to remove those obstacles and
connect to this Source this energy to
achieve what he calls the higher levels
of awareness by recognizing that we have
the power the energy and the capacity to
be able to do amazing things this isn't
something that's only reserved for
professional athletes artists CEOs or
world leaders it doesn't matter who you
are or what you want to create in your
life whether you want to be physically
fit financially free healthy or happy
just know that there are higher levels
of awareness that are available to us
that allow us to do things like manage
the coincidences in our lives by placing
our attention on things we'd like to
create for ourselves we can use this
energy to make contact with and manage
it we have the ability to communicate
with this infinite intelligence when you
have a desire something you really want
you put that thought out there as an ask
a wish or a prayer when you do that it's
a message that you're sending out to the
universe and on the other side when you
receive a message from the universe
you'll get an intuition it comes to you
as some sort of foresight or extra
sensory perception a sixth sense that
you can't explain
some people have difficulty contacting
this energy they're sending out prayers
thoughts messages asks but not receiving
anything in return why is it that some
people are able to communicate with the
Divine intelligence and manifest what
they want and others just can't do it
are they special the chosen ones or just
lucky do they have something you don't
what obstacles are in the way of
reaching higher levels of awareness
what we have to look at is basically the
obstacles
that we have conditioned ourselves
and you notice I say that we have
conditioned ourselves because I have
never believed that we need to be
putting the responsibility on someone
else if you're conditioned it's because
you have allowed yourself to become that
and if we are conditioned if we
conditioned ourselves to believe certain
kinds of things
and one of the things that we kind of
believe and hang on to and live with is
this whole idea that uh
all of the things that happened to me in
my past
are what are keeping me from doing what
I'd like to do today have you ever met a
person that blames their past for
everything that's happened to them they
aren't where they want to be right now
and they're constantly stuck in
miserable situations because of things
that happened years ago to them they
have stories like how they don't have a
higher education or the opposite they
Wasted Years of their life getting a
useless degree they didn't have
supportive parents or their parents were
too overbearing they grew up in a
household that didn't have much their
City lacked opportunities their life
isn't the way they want it to be because
of how events unfolded in the past
they're putting self-imposed limits on
their dreams they hang on to those past
events and use them as excuses this is
what Wayne Dyer calls the Wake what is
the Wake what is it what is this thing
that you see the wake is the trail
that is Left Behind nothing more nothing
less it's the trail that is Left Behind
it's all those experiences in your past
your history everything has happened to
you everyone has awakened but one of the
problems that most people have is they
have a tendency to look at the wake and
obsess over it using it as justification
for why their life isn't the way they
want it to be the wake is a science term
from physics used to describe the wave
pattern on the water when an object goes
through it like boats and Jet Skis leave
a wake behind them when they travel
through water Wayne Dyer has a great
metaphor to explain this imagine your
life is a boat going in One Direction as
it's going across the water it leaves
behind awake is it possible for the Wake
to change the direction of the boat no
it can't the only thing that can move
the boat is the present moment energy
that's being generated by the engine
it's only your thoughts in the present
moment that can steer the direction of
the boat the wake is nothing but the
trail that's left behind it's just a
reminder minor of where you've been it
doesn't Define or control where you're
going Wayne's personal experience with
the Wake was about his father who left
his family and forced Wayne to grow up
in a series of foster homes until his
mom struggled to get the family back
together through years of hardship Wayne
hated his father who never sent a penny
and never made a phone call who spent
some time in prison and was an alcoholic
he passed away from sirosis of the liver
linked to excessive alcohol consumption
Wayne never got to meet his father in
his adult life
and I actually went to my father's grade
to piss on his grave I did that's that's
where I was at that time I was filled
with rage I just couldn't imagine
somebody treating my beautiful mother
the way that he treated her and just
abandoning three children it just isn't
something that I could process in it at
this time Wayne was in a dark place a
low point in his life he was overweight
he was drinking doing drugs in a
terrible relationship and his writing
wasn't going anywhere but for some
reason he decided to go back to his
father's grave as I started to drive
away a voice something and energy called
me back it's a calling and I went back
to my father's grave
and something came over me in that
moment something that changed the entire
course of my life I blurted out loud and
I had no idea because I wasn't in the
Consciousness that I live in today I
blurted out loud
from this moment on
I'm sending you love who am I
to judge you or anyone given the
conditions of your life you did what you
knew how to do you can't ask any more of
anyone I let go I was sobbing and I was
free I forgave my father it wasn't until
he forgave his father that he let go of
all the anger and hatred and left it all
behind him in his wake his past he left
it in the trail that's left behind and
nothing more the weight was lifted from
his shoulders releasing all the
negativity and allowing the infinite
intelligence to start flowing through
him it allowed him to reach higher
levels of awareness shortly after his
writing took off at a much higher level
and I wrote
and I wrote morning noon and night I
hardly even ate one night I wrote so
much I wrote 77 pages one night and I
forgot the number of the pages
it's when you let go and just allow this
infinite intelligence to flow through
you that magical things begin to happen
he wrote his first book your erroneous
Zone several months later which became
the number one best-selling book in the
World published now in 40 different
languages and over 35 million copies
were printed only after he let go of his
past was able to change his life and
achieve the greatness that was always
inside of him
we take a look at all of these things in
our way and I'm not saying here that you
shouldn't be in touch with your past and
all of the things that are back there
but to use it as excuses for why you
can't get where you'd like to get today
if you do that you will never get to
this place that I'm talking about in
this program which is this place that I
call higher awareness Way Beyond
ordinary human awareness people who live
their days in ordinary human awareness
have certain ideas about what is
possible for themselves and the people
around them because that's all they know
they haven't experienced anything else
they try to impose their beliefs on
others these ideas have come from past
experiences popular opinions or
mainstream theories I know you've
experienced something like this before
at some point in your life a person has
tried to force their narrow view of the
world onto you and make you believe the
things that they believe it usually
sounds something like this you don't
have the ability it's too risky for you
you're not the right fit you're just
it's not good enough you're too old
you're too young these people aren't
acting maliciously oftentimes it's
coming from a good place and they
believe it's actually good advice by
what they deem as being realistic
choosing a sensible option and trying to
keep your thoughts grounded in their
version of reality and everything that
you believe in was handed to you by
someone else outside of you was handed
to you by the experiences or testimony
of someone in the past and because it
comes from outside of you
there is still an element of doubt and
this element of Doubt isn't bad but it
keeps you from reaching higher levels
because what you think about is what
expands and if you're thinking doubt
then doubt is what expands Wayne tells a
story that explains the difference in
the beliefs of people who live in
ordinary awareness versus people at
higher levels of awareness it's a fable
about three philanthropists trying to
help a nation of people who are
imprisoned they're a group that was
captured because they were on the wrong
side of a conflict and are being held as
prisoners of War these three
philanthropists had great wealth and
wanted to help the oppressed people the
first philanthropist found out that the
prisoners did not have fresh water so he
donated his entire Fortune to buy
purifiers and Water Supplies making sure
that the people would not suffer from
dehydration and waterborne diseases he
felt that he had fulfilled his Destiny
and saved people from illness the second
philanthropist found out that the
prisoners did not have enough to eat so
he donated his entire Fortune to provide
food make ensure the prisoners would not
be hungry he felt that he had fulfilled
his Destiny and saved the people from
starvation the third philanthropist was
living at higher levels of consciousness
when he found out that the people were
imprisoned he went looking for the keys
to the prison and released all the
people this story explains that when
you're living with ordinary levels of
awareness there's nothing wrong with
helping relieve the suffering of the
people around you what you're doing is
helping people suffer in Comfort but
when you're connected to higher levels
of awareness you have access to the
special keys to open those prisons and
end suffering altogether
where we can take the keys and unlock
the self-imposed prisons or the prisons
that we have given ourselves on the
basis of what we have come to believe is
our limitations what we can and can't do
we have to let go of that and I call it
rewriting our agreement with reality we
literally have to make a a whole new
contract with what it is that I perceive
to be what is possible for me Wayne Dyer
has a formula for manifestation that he
calls the four reallys people who are
able to get what they desire
consistently practice this some people
call them lucky some people call them
highly spiritual some people call them
blessed whatever it may be they are
great at getting what they want out of
life and it's because they follow this
method and this formula is one that
everyone
that I know who is able to get things
into their life practices this
I call it the four reallys
so that what you really really really
really
want
you will get and these four really stand
each of them stands for something the
first really in this formula is I wish
what do you really wish for everything
you would like to get in your life
starts with a thought a wish I wish I
could get that job I wish to lose weight
I wish to get rid of that addiction I
wish to be paid more
the second really is I desire what you
really desire is not the same as wishing
the difference is asking ask and you
shall receive be willing to ask the
infinite intelligence of the universe
and just like I mentioned earlier we
communicate with this intelligence by
asking and it responds by sending us an
intuition that feeling in your gut when
you know something is right that's Sixth
Sense
the third really is I intend what do you
really intend to create it can be
whatever you want I intend on creating
Prosperity I intend on losing weight I
intend of getting rid of an addiction
have you ever noticed that people who
are great at manifesting what they want
have certainty in how they approach
things they use language like I will do
it I deserve it I will complete that and
if it doesn't go their way it's just a
learning experience they take the
knowledge from the experience and apply
it to their future endeavors when
setting intentions you want them to be
so powerful that it becomes independent
of people's opinions you should feel
indifferent about others judgment it's a
spiritual journey within you to get
inspired by what you intend to manifest
the fourth really is Passion what you
are really passionate about you'll
attract into your life because if you
lack passion you won't be able to
manifest properly Wayne Dyer explains it
like this to attempt to manifest what
you want without passion is like
dressing up a corpse
so you take this corpse
and you put a tuxedo on it and you dress
it all up and you put all the makeup on
it and you take it out into the world
and you say now see what you can get for
me but basically it's dead inside
and if it's dead inside that is if it
lacks passion if you lack passion you're
not going to be able to attract it into
your life so what you wish for ask for
intend to create
and have passion about you'll get
you'll get it
that's the good news for some more
incredible Wayne Dyer motivation check
the video right there next to me I think
you'll love it continue to believe and
I'll see you there and these top 10
principles that I have put together here
for this program you might want to jot
down you might want to go into your desk
and just take out a little piece of
paper